what words would you give to somebody
like Victor who was just starting about
managing expectations of others and
separating that from yourself yeah like
yesterday like I felt for him because
people want to talk about his his
performance on that game he's going to
have so many amazing games I think he
already does a good job like I've seen
his interviews I don't think he's one of
those guys who's going to get way too
high way too low but that's the danger
of if you can't figure out how to find
that mental strength to not get too high
or too low he had one bad game and now
people are talking a certain way about
him you know it's hard like all these
people following them around all this
media it's just a lot for a kid that
over there was just able to play a free
game of basketball now you come to the
NBA and it's all about this other stuff
is involved that's why I think some
people the love for the game gets lost
in the NBA it's part of it it's your job
at that point